121,000 and 11/9 pause the video and
find the quotient and the remainder
did you try dividing the number by nine
using the traditional approach nine
times one is nine
twelve minus nine is three get the one
down and nine times three is 27 and so
on this is a bit tedious let's
understand a better and a much quicker
approach to divide numbers by nine first
we write the dividend as is once the
dividend is written we copy the first
digit down and add this with the second
digit one plus two is three then we add
this result to the next digit three plus
one is four
let's review the steps first digit
copied added it to the second digit to
get a result then added the result with
the third digit to get four we continue
this until we reach the last digit 4
plus 0 is 4 4 plus 1 is 5 and 5 plus 1
is 6 yes there's a reason why we have
written this in a different color 6 is
the remainder and this part is the
quotient yes we cut the quotient as well
as the remainder without performing the
division process we simply wrote the
first digit as this added it to the next
digit added the results to the
respective next digits until we reach
the last digit the last sum becomes the
remainder and the remaining number
becomes the quotient let's try out
another one 230 1062 divided by 9
find the quotient and the remainder
pause the video take your time and try
finding the quotient and the remainder
the
was simple we just have to write the
dividend as is with a slight gap between
each digit then we write the first digit
down as this after which we find the
series of sums 2 plus 3 is 5 5 plus 1 is
6 6 plus 0 is equal to 6 6 plus 6 is
equal to 12 now we cannot write a
two-digit number here so we write a 12
like this one under a 6 & 2 here and 12
plus 2 is equal to 14 interesting as 1
is written under the 6 we add them to is
written down 6 plus 1 is 7 6 5 & 2 now
my question to you is is 25,000 672 the
quotient and is 14 the remainder if you
use your calculator and multiply 25,000
672 with 9 and add 14 to the product you
will get 230 1062 which is our dividend
but this is incorrect why is it
incorrect tell me has the remainder ever
been greater than the divisor let me
give you an example if we divide 16 by 3
we write the quotient as 5 and the
remainder as 1 right or do we write the
quotient as 4 and the remainder as 4
undoubtedly the first one is correct so
all we need to do now is remove a line
from this and add 1 to the quotient
removing 9 from this gives us a
remainder of 5 and we add 1 to the
quotient this is our remainder if you
look at the second case of 16 over 3 you
can see that subtracting 3 from the
remainder and adding 1 to the quotient
will give us the first case that's
exactly what we have done here now we
simply perform the addition 2 plus 1 is
3 6 plus 1 is 7 6 5 - that's our
quotient 25,000 673 and the remainder is
5 don't worry if you haven't understood
it well
go through the video again and we will
also be looking at two more examples of
division by nine in the next part of the
session